this article right here gives me a lot
of Hope and excitement writer a normally
very pessimistic person talks about the
journey I'm trying to go through and try
different tactics mentally and tangibly
of changing their perspective
and and her conclusion at the end was
like look I'm not going to be the most
naturally bubbly person but changing
your perspective and just choosing
fighting for no different than doing
exercise no different than studying for
tests like putting in the work to
default into a more optimistic point of
view versus a pessimistic point of view
really does actually matter to overall
happiness this is going to be the great
debate and evolution and education for
society over the next hundred years
perspective really matters fighting for
it we learned to exercise in the last
half century we're going to learn to
fight for practical optimism we're in an
extreme place of pessimism now and I
think that's the beginning of this
journey